[Musique]
les rues prendre un vaste pirateurs peut
plus gagner du temps sur le ménage ou
pas on a déjà essayé elle préfère les
faux pas ce que c'est que cette horrible
ouais je suis stressé on repart la
chambre des masses d'après midi voilà et
la peinture c'est hyper nocifs pour les
bébés je sais pas qui l'a confié j'ai
personnes bien damazine complètement cas
bien oui attends je lis ton frère j'ai
29 ans je commence un peu à se connaître
tu peux me l'a confié enfin choix t'es
sérieux là tu veux que je te confie mon
enfant alors que tu es 2 % y sont morts
parce que tu vas donnez pas à manger
alors déjà excuse-moi la nourriture aux
poissons c'est extrêmement dur à trouver
et en plus sur la deux poissons falk est
mort c'est parce qu'il va très bien
alema direct en temps un petit peu oui
tu n'es pas content on regarde y'a pas
un super content alors tu m'a confié ou
pas ok je la fais attention
[Musique]
être adulte c'est parfois être
responsable de quelqu'un sait ce que
c'est que ça ça c'est des couches c'est
pour toi t'as pas être très jeunes
soient très bien à cyprien c'est vrai
qu'avec la tout aussi normal j'étais
tout noté la 1c le moindre problème que
je t'appelle il m'appelle très bien ok
bon d'un coup là la poussette et dans
l'entrée à la maison tu oublies nous
donner à l'ema tu t'entends chao et moi
j'adore les mouvements pas de mômes
norman enfin j'adore les mômes des
autres quoi on en oublie cette phase
c'était chez nous parce que vous allez
diable mais qu il semblerait selon m oui
merde allez on va les jouer poser chacun
d'accord nous faisons nos courses crabes
tu vas voir emma celui ci il aspire
vraiment tu vas adorer up est c'est
parti reviendra sur la poussière
[Applaudissements]
on arrête tout c'était la pire du monde
on fait quoi on va se promener super
dans un magasin ont validé jeudi le
clavier les p&t la touche une marche
plus quoi crucialement des phrases sans
la est trop peu puissante enquête tout w
en transit your dreams l'informatique je
sais pas s'il va rester tout un clavier
quand même juste pour attouchements tu
peux acheter qu à tout ce que tu as
perdu 1 c'est plus aucun bruit norman et
pudeur
marie bat est mort est mort et matteo et
moi et moi
tomber la mémoire des morts
qui joue à l'accueil
moi
ok désolé désolé c'est une urgence
on a perdu en un instant dans le magasin
a pas de problème on va faire une
annonce
alors comment il s'appelle et vêtements
c'est une fille est mort nous
recherchons une petite fille qui n'a pas
de prénom et qui se font sentir est là
sauf pour l'élève nous l'attendons à
l'accueil du magasin
eva et moi c'est bien pour starsky saint
éloi des touches de clavier alignera
confié bon ou est-ce qu'une enfant de 3
ans mesure déjà pas dans un magasin
bricolage c'est sûr sinon pour le rayant
dramatique c'est au fond à droite après
les micro ondes et les aspirateurs tu
vas où
m
julie ça va bon voilà en tout cas de
dire c'est un détail hier mais il m'a a
disparu sinon c'est bien ça avance les
peintures à l'eau joli bon j'ai un truc
à dire non c'est vrai qu'il ya un truc à
dire non même écoute je suis désolé j'ai
tout tétouan alors que tu es mon frère
est la personne qui se parent le plus
confiance et puis je suis certaine que
tu t'occupes hyper bien démarre
ça me touche ah ouais t'as raison c'est
vrai que je vais plutôt bien au moral le
petit frère ouais c'est clair
elle est où là elle fait quoi elle va
bien bah ouais elle va bien à mon avis
way
à ton avis du coup at-on habile et où
elle est où la passe là moi je te
rappelles tu aimes l'aspirateur surtout
tu dis pas maintenant que tu es perdu à
ok tu me dis pas non voilà exactement
manama main
yes i sava howey que vous faites là est
vraiment les deux fonds prêtés tout
blanc je dois je passe ma couleur
naturelle sa colère nature on rentre à
la maison en bois de d'où vous venez la
caisse
starsky tout seul son coéquipier
j'y vais merci ciao bisous bisous la
sauce pour l'om n'en porte quoi
[Musique]